we have a voicemail number which you can  call anytime  the number is 2192 david p  here is a call from a guy who is very  happily voting trump take a listen  i am voting for president trump by the  way the requisite show playing in the  background it's always a it's a staple  of these phone calls  ain't nobody sit up there and lie  all you want to i am voting for  president trump the best president i  ever lived  god bless you and thank you  right so remember you can't talk a guy  out of that  in the 10 weeks we have left don't even  bother  we just have to get the vote out  remember that we've got a great bonus  show for you today  we will talk about uh reports of new  york city's demise being greatly  exaggerated we will talk about  differences in coverage of the  conventions on corporate media and  much much more make sure to get instant  access to the bonus show by becoming a  member at joinedpakman.com  or a patron at patreon.com  david pakman show